Y
ATTENTION TO A LOT COMING AT
THEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS ON
VACCINES FROM OVERSEAS.
RESEARCH FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
OXFORD IN ENGLAND OUT THIS
MORNING HAS NEW DATA REGARDING
THOSE RARE CASES OF BLOOD
CLOTTING IN COVID PATIENTS AND
VACCINE RECIPIENTS.
CBS NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR,
DR. DAVID AGUS, JOINS US.
GOOD MORNING.
WE NEED TO POINT OUT THAT THIS
STUDY HAS NOT YET BEEN PEER
REVIEWED.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> THIS IS A STUDY WHERE THEY
PULLED DATA FROM LARGE NUMBERS
OF HOSPITALS, PREDOMINANTLY IN
THE UNITED STATES.
THE MOST I THINK IMPORTANT
FINDING IS IS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BLOOD CLOT IN THE
BRAIN CALLED CEREBRAL THROMBOSIS
HAPPENS TEN TIMES MORE THAN
PEOPLE WITH THE VIRAL INFECTIONS
CHANCE VACCINE.
PEOPLE WITH A VOYEURS HAVE MORE
INCIDENCE OF THIS RARE BLOOD
CLOT IN THE BRAIN.
>> IT SHOWS THAT MODERNA AND
PFIZER VACCINES HAVE A SIMILAR
RATE OF BLOOD CLOTS TO
ASTRAZENECA AND JOHNSON &
JOHNSON.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> YEAH.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS IS THAT
THIS IS AN EFFECT IN ALL OF THE
VACCINES, IS THAT ABOUT A TENTH
IS COMMON.
IN THIS STUDY THERE WERE TWO IN
500,000 PEOPLE WITH THE MODERNA
AND THE PFIZER.
SO A RATE OF FOUR PER MILLION.
ACTUALLY MORE THAN THE JOHNSON &
JOHNSON.
BUT DRAMATICALLY LOWER THAN IF
YOU HAD THE VIRUS.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT OBSERVATION,
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO CHANGE
NOW BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PREVENT THESE AND TREAT
THESE EARLY AS WE DEVELOP
STRATEGIES.
>> HOW SHOULD THE GOVERNMENT
RESPOND IN THIS CASE, DAVID?
THY PAUSED THE JOHNSON &
JOHNSON VACCINE.
IS THAT WILL SOMETHING THEY NEED
-- IS THAT SOMETHING THEY NEED
TO CONSIDER WITH THE OTHER
VACCINES?
>> YEAH, NO, THAT'S A CRITICAL
POINT.
MY GUT IS THAT THE JOHNSON &
JOHNSON VACCINE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE ADMINISTERED AFTER THE
COMMITTEE MEETS AGAIN IN A WEEK.
ADVISORY COMMITTEE MET YESTERDAY
EXPECT SAID THEY'LL MAKE A
DECISION IN SEVEN TO TEN DAYS.
MY GUT IS WE'RE GOING TO GET
BACK ON THE VACCINE TRAIN HERE
AND VACCINATE PEOPLE TO PREVENT
THE HORRIBLE COMPLICATIONS FROM
THE VIRUS.
THIS IS MORE EVIDENCE OF THE
VACCINE HELPING PEOPLE IN A
DRAMATIC WAY FROM THE RAVAGES OF
COVID-19.
>> THE HEADLINE AGAIN, AS YOU
SAID, IS THAT YOU'RE MORE LIKELY
TO GET BLOOD CLOTS FROM THE
COVID VIRUS, SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
THAN YOU WOULD FROM ANY VACCINE.